іноземний
[Музика]
іноземний [Музика]
іноземний [
Музика]
[Оплески] іноземний іноземний [
іноземний [Музика
] [
Оплески] [Музика]
іноземний [Музика]
іноземний [
Музика]
дякую
[Музика]
[Оплески]
іноземний
[Музика  ]
дякую
іноземні
[Музика]
Я згоден з усіма вами і хотів би
негайно виправити одну несправедливість, ця панельна дискусія
називається Давид на Нефроні.
Я вважаю це справедливою повагою до
України та всього, що є нашим народом
роблю,
але цього року рішучість була продемонстрована на
різних берегах і не лише на
непро,
і кажучи, що Темза, Потомак, Вішла та
Тибер, Девід тепер усі ми,
він є цілим вільним світом, це
всі, хто пішов, що немає
альтернативи, окрім як перемогти  Голіаф,
який прийшов, щоб знищити наше життя,
будучи Давидом,
будучи Давидом, бореться, і ми
боремося, будучи Давидом, маємо пращу,
щоб перемогти, у нас ще немає
пращі Давида з Ізраїлю, але я думаю, що це
лише
тимчасово,
я хотів би подякувати за
потужна підтримка та потужна зброя.
Я дякую всім і Еммануелю, які
присутні тут, на цій панелі, і я дякую
всім нашим партнерам, присутнім тут, у Мюнхені,
Сполученим Штатам, Британії, усім
країнам ЄС і всім з
усього світу, я вдячний  всі, хто
дає це посилання на українського Давида, завдяки
чому російський
Голіаф
вже почав втрачати свої позиції
дякую велике дякую [
Оплески]
велике дякую
ми бачили це минулого року і
він точно впаде вже цього
року ми  ми можемо зробити це всі разом
так само, як це зробив Девід, ми можемо переконатися, що
немає альтернативи нашій Перемозі,
але тоді не повинно бути альтернативи
нашій рішучості рішучості
всіх нас щодо ніпро та
розпилювача щодо побачення на Темзі на
Потомак і Вішла на Тибрі, потім ти,
Йорданія і всюди в кожній частині
світу, де свобода цінується більше,
ніж милість тирана,
минулого року,
коли я був тут,
у Мюнхені, на конференції, я
шукав такої спільної рішучості, що
Україна була  чітко сказати світові, що ми
будемо боротися за себе, якщо Росія
почне повномасштабну війну,
я хотів почути від світу Україна,
ми будемо з вами,
на жаль, я почув це лише після того, як
російські ракети вдарили по нашій землі вже
після того, як російські танки почали рухатися
вже після  Путін знищив усі
Альтернативи, живе тільки один, хто
переможе, він чи ми,
насправді ви вже відповіли
назвою цих конференцій панельна
дискусія У Голіафа немає шансів,
але, на жаль, у нього є потенціал,
на жаль, він намагається виграти додатковий
час для своєї агресії, торгуючи з
світ, на жаль, він все ще може знищити
Багато життів Багато, тому нам потрібно
поспішати, нам потрібна швидкість швидкість наших
угод швидкість нашої доставки, щоб
зміцнити нашу пращу швидкість рішень,
щоб обмежити російський потенціал,
немає альтернативи швидкості, тому що це
швидкість, від якої залежить життя від
затримки, завжди була і залишається
загадкою, поки ми домовляємося, як
посилити нашу оборону сучасними танками
Кремль, ти думаєш, думаєш,
як задушити Молдову, а ми
намагаємося переконати, що Україні
потрібна сучасна бойова авіація  Кремль
уже переконав іранський режим,
що результатом є не лише смертоносні іранські
безпілотники в українському небі, але й
щось, за
що Кремль заплатив за це,
ви впевнені, що це просто гроші,
чи, можливо, світ зіткнеться зі
збагаченим іранським режимом
і до чого
90 92 або 100 відсотків,
і я впевнений, що ніхто з нас не хоче дозволити
регіону
Близького Сходу та Перської затоки спробувати його,
поки ми витратили тижні на те, щоб узгодити нові
санкції проти Росії. Третя держава
шукає способи  адаптуватися до
обмежень, які вже діють
через паралельний імпорт Тіньовий флот
танкерів тощо,
де ми побачимо вплив цього
незаконного пророка Росії
в зусиллях корумпувати ваші політичні
системи та міжнародні інституції
в спробах дестабілізувати ваше соціальне
життя та в цьому  інформаційні кампанії
проти вашого народу
в ескалації в тих регіонах, які
чутливі до вас,
що марнотратство, наприклад, Лівія,
Малі чи Центрально-Африканська Республіка, поки
Москва мала владу,
що чекає на Сирію, нічого хорошого, як і в
багатьох інших націй, тому вам також не буде
відпочинку, тому  справа не лише в
Україні, справа в тому, що Голіаф має
програти,
і цьому немає альтернативи,
тому що Кремль може порушити
безпеку та спокій усіх, хто зараз
представлений тут, у Мюнхені, відстрочені
рішення світу є ресурсом,
на який живе диктатура Путіна  так було роками,
чим довше тривали розмови про
розширення Європейського Союзу, чим більше
руйнівності
Кремль вносив у сіру зону
між Європейським Союзом і Росією,
тим голосніше говорилося, що
потрібно почекати, перш ніж
дозволять Україні  увійти до відкритих дверей НАТО,
чим агресивнішою ставала російська політика, чим
довше тривало мовчання щодо Криму в
глобальному порядку денному, тим сильнішим
ставав російський реваншизм і чим більше
світ сперечався про те, які санкції та
коли запровадити проти Росії, тим
безсоромнішими ставали амбіції Кремля
чим довше у нас в Україні в Європі в
світі не було Єдності тим більше
ілюзій у Росії було тепер
зараз все це виправляється
так само як
минулого року я зараз пропонував діяти
негайно але на відміну від минулого року
зараз у мене є найпереконливіший аргумент
наші досягнення чи
можемо ми  стримувати російські удари так чи можемо ми
захистити наші міста від російських ракет
точно чи можемо ми звільнити нашу землю Цьому
є
1891 підтвердження це саме
скільки міст містечок сіл нам вдалося
звільнити від російської окупації
чи можемо ми відновити безпеку в Чорноморському
регіоні та  продовольча безпека у світі
Чорноморська зернова ініціатива та
гуманітарна ініціатива зерно з
України переконують чи
Україні час бути
повноцінною частиною Європейського Союзу
більшість європейців підтримують членство
України ми вже отримали статус
кандидата  країна ми вже
готуємось розпочати
переговори про членство ми вже об’єднані з
європейською економікою Логістика та
енергетика цього немає немає
альтернативи українській перемозі немає альтернативи
Україні та
в ЄС немає альтернативи
Україні в НАТО
є  немає
жодної альтернативи нашій Єдності,
отже, немає
і не повинно бути жодної альтернативи
повністю позбутися російської агресії,
щоб звільнити землю,
щоб звільнити людей, тому що кожне
місто та село, яке залишається під
окупацією, означає, що люди залишаються в
полоні, можуть бути люди суб’єктами
компромісу ні, ми повинні звільнити
Україну та Європу, тому що коли
російська зброя стріляє в нас, вона вже
спрямована на наших сусідів.
Нехай Європа буде предметом компромісу
ні, ми повинні звільнити від
агресивного потенціалу Росії всі
міжнародні інституції та кожен рівень
світова економіка, тому що
тільки тоді буде шанс
для свободи пройти через наш кордон
далі на схід
моя свобода бути предметом компромісу
ні і це твердо ні Я
впевнений, що ми можемо здобути Перемогу не
тільки над Путіним  але й над Путіним
не лише над Путіним у Росії, але й у всьому
світі чи
не це буде доказом сили
ідеї свободи, це точно
буде,
пані та панове,
рішучість ніколи не є абстрактною
Давид переміг Голіафа не
силою  розмови, але силою
цих дій
мужністю та мужністю – це те, що
ми маємо,
її вистачає не лише в Україні, а й у
всій нашій Коаліції Перемоги, цей
зв’язок має міцніти прямо зараз,
щоб наступного року ми зібралися  тут,
у Мюнхені, для меншої кількості
післявоєнної конференції з питань безпеки за умови
вільної України, вільної Європи, вільного світу,
всі Еммануїли, усі наші друзі, і я,
всі Еммануелі, так, усі наші друзі, я
думаю, я думаю, ви мене правильно зрозуміли, дякую,
дякую  дуже дякую вам,
Давиде вільного світу, ми об’єднані,
Давид переможе над Путіним,
розкиданий по всьому світу, слава
всім, хто зараз на полі бою,
славо зелений,
велике спасибі,
пане президенте, велике спасибі за
ваші слова, коли ми  деякий час тому запитав вас,
чи збираєтеся ви відвідати Мюнхенську
конференцію з безпеки, ви сказали,
що добре, я буду там особисто,
коли закінчиться війна, тож ми сподіваємося
вітати вас, як ви вказали, наступного року
тут у Мюнхені
[Оплески],
але  щодо того самого питання, якщо можна, пане
президенте, президент
Путін явно розраховує на
втому міжнародного
співтовариства та втому вашої
країни від зниження стійкості,
він вважає, що Росія має більшу
владу, ніж Україна, ви поділяєте його думку
сьогодні ввечері
та  він збирається відповісти українською,
гм,
іноземною, ну
дуже дякую, пане президенте,
тепер ми побачили, що Росія
вже намагається отримати деякі дані, щоб почати
своєрідний наступ,
мм, моє запитання, як ви думаєте, що це
триватиме й чи стурбовані ви тим, що,
можливо,  Білорусь приєднається, а
лукашенко приєднається до Путіна в
нападі на вашу країну
іноземні
[Музика]
завтра [
Музика]
гм
іноземні
а звіти
є тероризм
тероризм
це іспанська судо Трибуналізм
синій
іноземний
дякую вам велике спасибі пане
президенте моє останнє запитання  про
майбутнє вашої власної країни ви
продемонстрували в українському суспільстві
велику внутрішню солідарність, моє
запитання полягає в тому, чи ця єдність, яка, на мою
думку, є дуже важливою, чи
триватиме це після війни, а також щодо,
якщо я можу це сказати, щодо ендемії
корупція, свідками якої ми були у вашій
країні раніше, як ви думаєте,
гмм, ця дандемічна корупція буде
вирвана з корінням гм назавжди, так, так [
Музика]
це [
іноземне,
дякую вам, пане президенте, і я
думаю, що я говорю від імені всіх  коли я дякую
вам за ваше втручання
сьогодні вдень, і ми бажаємо вам і
вашим людям удачі, і ми зробимо
все можливе також тут, на Мюнхенській
конференції з безпеки, щоб справді підтримати
вашу справу, ви також захищаєте нашу
свободу, тож велике вам спасибі
за те, що ви з нами, бажаю вам удачі, пане
президенте,
безперечно, велике спасибі
всім, удачі та миру, дякую за
підтримку,
так, пані та панове, я прошу вас
тримати навушники, тому що зараз це
велика честь і приємно вітати
на  вдруге зареєструватися на Мюнхенську
конференцію з питань безпеки Канцлер Олаф
Шульц
іноземні
іноземні [
Оплески]
іноземні
дозвольте мені особливо тепло
привітати віце-президента
Сполучених Штатів, дякую, що
ще раз приєдналися до конференції, я можу додати,
що для мене це честь  Ви тут з нами
разом із такою кількістю колег із
Сенату США, Палати представників
та адміністрації, вітаємо всіх
вас у Мюнхені
[Оплески]
іноземні іноземні іноземні
freiheit
зрозуміли [
Оплески]
Європа,
на жаль, не
іноземні
[Оплески] дякую
ви,
отже, все
ще для іноземного
добра робить Мюнхенську конференцію з безпеки
це
іноземний
партнер
тоді
іноземний
інтенсивний
поліцейський
іноземний
імплантат
і він [
Оплески]
Європа —
це
система,
яку франшиза вважається основною наземною
бойовою системою
—
ініціатива Щит
Європа
іноземна
Ірація
democratulations
іноземні
іноземні іноземні іноземні
на цій шпильці 4 чи президент XI від disa
Gilligan мав духовенство
це
Європа повинна позбутися уявлення про те,
що проблеми Європи є
проблемами світу, але проблеми світу
не є проблемами Європи
іноземні іноземні іноземні
[Музика]
іноземні
[  Оплески]
дякую вам,
пане канцлер,
цього разу минулого року я мав честь
сидіти тут із президентом Зєлінським,
Сполучені Штати сказали йому, що, можливо, вам
не варто залишати свою країну, тому що
щось може статися, але він прийшов сюди
і